[Musique]
bonne nouvelle aujourd'hui à regarder ça
j'ai reçu j'ai été le chercher
j'ai un nouveau paquet avec plein de
smartphones hyper plus lors vous le
savez pas ce que vous avez effectivement
cliquez sur la vidéo de cette annonce
est dans le titre je sais je peux pas
vous l'utilisez vous savez exactement ce
qu'on va pas d'aujourd'hui en fait il ya
trois nouveaux produits qui ont été
reçus ces trois derniers smartphones
haut de gamme de samsung que son aile et
samsung galaxy s 20 ans voire plus et
s20 il trappe
ils sont là faisant un peu de cash et ne
montrent la page nous regarde toi alors
aujourd'hui l'exercice
ça va être de faire un nom boxing la
question c'est est ce que samsung a fait
un emballage différentes ces différents
modèles entre le bien évidemment le
moins cher que m le réseau mais qui
entraîne un modèle très haut de gamme et
le s20 ultras qui luttera hozjan qui ne
font pas débat comme ça maintenant et ça
va donc on va regarder ça on va se poser
deux côtés est-ce qu'à une vraie
différenciation j'ai l'impression qu'ils
causent mois de ça comme ça à travers là
je vois un petit modèle blanc et là j'ai
deux modèles noirs sans rien savoir je
pense là en alu est sauf elle va plus
c'est l'ultra un peu comme ça donc on va
se mettre par là bas on va se regarder
ça d'euros et puis on va voir au final
quelle proposition de valeur nous ferez
là-dessus samsung par rapport à ces
boîtes ça montre effectivement s'il ya
une différence si ça me saoule fait
vraiment une différence entre ces
modèles au-delà du côté technologique
au delà du côté purement appareil photo
qu'est ce qu'ils peuvent nous apporter
et c'est ça qui est vraiment intéressant
parce que c'est la première fois que
samsung propose trois modèles dans le
très haut de gamme sur la gamme s
donc ça c'est cool et ça soulève pas de
questions en attendant on regarde ça je
vous arrête en effet des jolies plus
comme je vous dis c'est pour les nourrir
il faut que la vidéo de référence donc
des jolies pouces n'hésitez pas à vous
abonner tout ça ça vous intéresse pas ce
qu'on va parler avec plein de choses à
dire fameux lancement plein de
nouveautés pas d'actu et plein de trucs
vachement cool et bien évidemment si
vous avez des questions ou
interrogations suggestions compagnie
pourrait y aller en bar aux commentaires
voilà l'équipement alors là on a le
nouveau matos de samsung sont les
nouveaux smartphones et bien évidemment
pour ouvrir un petit ciseau est ce que
c'est que samsung s'attaque au delà de
presse ça j'arrive pas à croire que ce
soit une boîte de smartphones mais à mon
avis ça c'est un modèle de près c'est
pour ça qu'il arrive comme ça je vois
pas sinon comment ça pourrait être
possible au quesnoy sept ans c'est ça
mais ça c'est les modèles qui sont
présentés pour ne pas fuité directement
et vous avez des informations
confidentielles
on ne peut pas faire de photos on ne
peut pas le vendre et on peut pas le
faire l'icop à faire suite à celle des
modèles qui sortent ce ne sont pas les
modèles industrialisés se sont vraiment
les modèles le tout premier modèle c'est
bien la première fois que je me retrouve
avec ce typologie de boîtes bon bah là
pour coup pour le boxing c'est très
atypique mais ça ressemble pas du tout à
ce que vous allez voir et vous qu'est ce
qui nous met en garde bien évidemment le
chargeur ça c'est un grand classique on
va se retrouver ici avec le câble de
charge des cdc ça roule
on a ici les petits écouteurs avec les
embouts à l'intérieur brouter vois ça ça
marche
alors voyez là pour le coup c'est la
grosse surprise parce que je pensais pas
du tout pour une me retrouver avec la
tête
ça ressemble davantage aux boîtes car
mon avis vous y retrouvez vous dans le
commerce ce qui très drôle voyaient leur
c'est un point de détail c'est que là
effectivement on écrit noir sur noir
apte à côté un petit peu brillant sur le
s20 plus tels que sur le s20 ultra pour
notre espèce de grease est toujours s'en
remettre format blanc on voit bien le
format du smartphone qu'ils dessinent
ici on est bien effectivement les
références nadir des modèles 5 g si vous
avez suivi mais le s vol cra c'est le
seul modèle à être uniquement 5 g et aux
5 g sur le s20 plus vous avez un modèle
cinq semaines vous avez un modèle 4g
également et c'est exactement la même
chose sur l'ès 20 vous avez un modèle 4g
vous avez un modèle 5 g ça permet
effectivement bien d'avoir un must run
un petit peu moins cher que ça vous
coûtera moins cher avec un modèle qui
n'est effectivement pas 5 g mais que par
contre vous n'allez pas pouvoir emmener
beaucoup plus loin dans le temps au toit
vous allez être limité si vous voulez
souscrire à une offre 5 janvier vous
pourrez pas nous faut vraiment réfléchir
moment de faire ce choix là il va
falloir rouvrir le petit saut de
protection regardez-moi ça comme c'est
tout mignon ça c'est la protection on
enlève également tout ce qui est numéro
de série en chez samsung et nous met des
films plastiques de tous les côtés y
compris ici vous voyez sur le côté alors
qu'est ce qu'on a à l'intérieur de la
boîte on soulève samsung est comme ça en
laisse dans le branding ça marche bon en
fait rien a complètement dingue qu'on va
voir
le chargeur rapide le câble usb usb
c'est on va voir ici les petits
écouteurs à kg avec les petits son bout
à l'intérieur on a par contre sur la
partie haute regarder ça avec votre
petite pique pour nourrir votre tiroir
de cartes s'initiant d'avoir les infos
que les cartes de garantie et compagnie
petit guide d'installation rapide la
carte de garantie beau il ya pas grand
chose à dire très simple en fait c'est
assez sommaire est ce qu'on va retrouver
dans cette boîte attend ce curieux de
voir ce que dans le modèle ultra est ce
qu'ils ont vraiment fait autre chose vu
qu'on est quand même sur un modèle le
plus cher est ce qui est une autre
expérience hockey à l'écouté j'ai
l'impression que c'est la même chose en
son temps
alors j'imagine qu'en termes d'industrie
dation c'est compliqué de faire des
choses différentes pour chaque boîte et
des petites variantes ne sort était bien
d'apporter une expérience un peu
différent peut-être sur le modèle le
plus haut de gamme parce que là c'est
exactement la même chose
bon ce smartphone je voulais déjà
présenté jeudi à bien tous présentés
lorsque j'étais à san francisco les
quelques jours donc on les connaît c'est
vraiment exactement la même chose on a
effectivement la même expérience entre
pour l'instant les deux smartphones
j'imagine que c'est la même chose sur
les 20 que ce soit sur le s20 plus qui
est ici sur le s20 ultras qui est là ou
sur facebook
c'est la même chose j'aurais aimé
partout qu'un petit peu différent voyez
vous l'avez même dit dans la vidéo de
une boxing du galaxy z flip pareil j'ai
pas été extrêmement surpris on reste
dans les mêmes codes cette année s'est
pas complètement dingue mais je pense
qu'effectivement le vrai intérêt la
vraie surprise ça se passe là dedans et
surtout ici au niveau du lait sera ultra
d'ailleurs son espace compte qu'il faut
protéger son but ultime ans voulait pas
les faire tomber risquer de les abîmer
parce que même s'ils sont sympas solide
et résistant et puis ils sont pas la
preuve de tous les chats justement pour
les protéger vous avez l'éventail de
produits de mon partenaire inochi allez
y à pleins qu'on attend et qu'est-ce que
j'ai l'âge une crash garde pour le
galaxy s 20 alors la crèche gardent leur
vin c'est celui là
l'idée de la crasse garde c'est que vous
venez le m tout autour ça vous permet de
garder le dos comme ça vous avez un dos
qui est jolie qui est sympa ça vous le
protège on a également une crash gains
pour le s venus traquer ce que j'ai ici
j'ai une crasse garde pour le s20 plus
aussi donc ça c'est cool et j'ai
notamment une coque de protection et les
[Applaudissements]
enlève ça déjà c'est une coque pour le
sml tra effet carbone regardez-moi ça
comme c'est mignon
joli petit coq c'est sympa on va bien
tout le module couteau qui sort pensez
vraiment à venir protéger vos
smartphones c'est extrêmement important
pour éviter si vous les échappés de les
casser
c'est pas non plus magique secondes du
30e étage un moment où vient se briser
mais pour tous les petits chocs du
quotidien stades vraiment venir vous
sauver la vie
j'ai une réduction pour vous wilko d'en
bas dans la description comme ça peut
profiter d'un tarif préférentiel
grâce à monsieur gros donc voilà penser
boîte j'ai une autre information
importante à vous donner j'ai reçu un
petit mail qui met quelques informations
sur ses smartphones
alors ça je le redirai lors du test mais
on a bien spécifié et ça il faut
vraiment le savoir est vraiment le
prendre en compte qu'une énorme mise à
jour du logiciel arrive début mars sur
lèze dans les smartphones pour l'instant
ils sont pas commercialisés pour les
précommandes aimez vous pourrez pas les
recevoir avant début mars
donc lorsque vous aurez vos smartphones
vous les mettrez à jour et vous aurez
cette mise à jour qui ont une très
grosse mise à jour qui arrivera début
mars sur les vins et sera la version
finale du soft ouvert que les
consommateurs auront dans les moeurs en
achetant promis donc lorsque vous
lorient mais pas une fin mais un jour
c'est encore mieux c'est magnifique
lorsque tu testera les produits dans les
jours à venir deux éléments majeurs ne
sont pas encore définitifs l'autonomie
et qui - tony va être améliorée par la
mise à jour ne sont pas vous donner un
avis sur l'autonomie par rapport à ce
que j'ai aujourd'hui
mais parions que savoir que sur vos
produits et biens l'autonomie sera
améliorée et sur la partie photo vidéo
une amélioration du mode single take qui
serait très très très cool je vous
montrerai ça d'ici quelques jours à new
york parce que je pars et je mets tout
vous tester la barre déjà le mode signe
de tequila hypra hypra cool l'année pts
et la qualité en basse lumière la
qualité du mode portrait là disponibles
qui des fichiers raw les ajouts diconne
ça va être encore mieux en terme
d'expérience
l'amélioration du traitement global des
photos de jour et de nuit l'amélioration
du mode ni l'amélioration de la netteté
en 108 et 64 mégapixels amélioration du
net des zooms l'amélioration de voudront
tout va être amélioré l'amélioration des
vidéos 8 qu'à l'amélioration de la
stabilisation sur les vidéos 8 qu'à
l'amélioration de l'autofocus
donc il va y avoir pas mal de mise à
jour pas mal de nouveautés sur ces
produits là donc on se les tests d'ici
quelques jours nous emmène avec moi à
new york on va cet été peut-être que
tout resterait avant le galaxy ace va
d'ailleurs dit moi est ce que vous
voulez que je vous fasse un test séparés
pour chaque smartphone est ce que vous
voulez un test de comparaison entre les
trois smartphones pour soit vraiment
lequel acheter est ce que vous voulez
test global pour les trois smartphones
est sur les rails outrage isole un test
photo vidéo parce qu'effectivement c'est
le gros usage de ce smartphone
dites moi ça m'a vraiment quelle manière
vrai que je le fasse en bas en
commentaire comme ça c'est vous qui
choisissez
sur ce je vous fais les gros bisous j'en
vois beaucoup d'amour des coeurs vous
pouvez mais c'est bien évidemment tous
vos commentaires des jolies pousse tout
ce que vous voulez en bas et puis quant
à nous on se retrouve dès demain pour
continuer à parler de teck et d'ici
quelques jours bien évidemment vous
emmener avec moi à new york comme ça à
pouvoir se tester et notamment le s20
ultra en photo avec son énorme zoom pour
aller ajouté des building très très loin
et ironie
ça va être hyper cool sur ce je vous
embrasse dans l'est demain
[Musique]
jégo qui doit pointer